hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
jacqueline alongside one of my favorite
people on the internet and in person mr
mark ellis how you doing sir hey look at
that wow i got i don't know why i got
the glowing intro jaclyn do do i owe you
money or something what what what
exactly are we okay now you did help me
get my twitter unhacked so i appreciate
that
i appreciate that too i'm very glad that
it happened that was actually one of my
favorite things that happened too
because mark unlocks his twitter and
then 10 seconds after i start roasting
him about the commanders because i
learned
which i did not know that only 27 or 28
percent of people that live in the
washington dc area support your team
okay first of all that number is 29
thank you
29
yeah when you watch our home games you
can really tell uh how little of a fan
base we have left because it's packed
with opposing fans and so hopefully we
rectify that this year with uh
oh my god i'm gonna stay optimistic
until the season starts look look
hopefully you know what stranger things
can have happened ah
get it oh that was sorry oh my god the
queen of transitions i'm sorry i had to
i was so excited about that one in my
head i couldn't even enjoy it like i
couldn't even like let it lay i'm just
so happy about it but yes that's because
this week
we're gonna turn the world upside down
ladies and gentlemen as we break down
seasons one through three of stranger
things that's because the first half of
season four premieres this month may
27th and season five is supposedly to be
the last but looking at the netflix
stock price i think they might keep
those kids limping into way past post
college because overall this is a huge
success for netflix 93 fresh on the
tomato meter 91 average on the audience
scores season one 97 96 season two 94 90
and then season three pulling up the
rear at 89.86 still
so incredible and we have a guest along
with us today i feel like he's straight
out of hawkins like i feel like he
really could wear one of those shirts
like he feels very much at home i feel
with the with our stranger things crew
this is eric striffler he's the creator
and host of pretty much it check it out
on his youtube channel it's a hilarious
movie and tv commentary show maybe he
gets an assist by somebody that's very
familiar to the pod named mr brian
pettis we'll talk about that later eric
how you doing sir i'm doing well and
yeah go tigers go hawkins tigers baby i
wish i had a hawkins tiger shirt right
now i don't last time i was on for the
mummy episode i had a whole wardrobe
thing planned and i don't have that this
time unfortunately but i'm very excited
to be back
talking stranger things especially
because i uh i feel like um i feel like
it's gonna be an interesting discussion
i i have some uh some thoughts and
opinions on the seasons that might
differ so very excited oh are you gonna
be loading up the hot take cannon cause
listen
i don't know it might be wow well eric's
always good for a hot take jacqueline
and here's what i love about eric the
most is that when when eric started out
and really when stranger things started
out i always looked at striffler as like
one of the kids on the bikes who's
looking for their friend will byers and
now eric you find yourself in the
position of being like one of the older
kids that isn't like the the adult yet
but you're also not one of the core kids
so you're just kind of that guy that
floats around in a van around town and
we're not sure if we can trust you or
not i was gonna say i've upgraded from a
bike to a van still hunting for uh for
kids though
in the woods you know whatever
you can find
exactly
well
let's get down to it eric is rotten
tomatoes wrong about
the season scores of stranger things uh
and is it right to have that ranking one
two three with one being the top three
being the bottom where do you feel
the ranking should be and do you feel
the scores are right uh no i feel it's
the exact opposite i think that each
season is better than the last with uh
well actually i shouldn't say is better
than last i think that the second season
is really not great but i think that the
third season is without a doubt the best
season of the show and so i'm not
surprised that it's it goes in order one
two three going lower each time just
because that feels for something that's
generally well received that just feels
like a common thing that would happen
anyway um but i do think personally that
the third season is
absolutely the best season of the show
even though the kids are getting older
which i think even works against the
show and the fact that it's still good
makes it even more impressive
yeah no i i i think the show is always
improving but i think like with anything
as somebody who rarely even the shows
that i love you'll hard press to get me
to watch past season four of the west
wing and i've seen that show probably a
hundred times
i like earlier episodes of shows because
if people know the logistics and
realities of creating television that's
sort of like the first couple of years
in like a political white house it's
like the dream team starts everything
off and then they slowly splinter off to
do other things alec berg eventually
does leave seinfeld and he goes and does
his thing you know that's sort of the
thing that happens with television shows
but honestly i think with stranger
things for the most part they've kept uh
they've kind of kept that core crew so
mark uh let me ask you is rotten
tomatoes wrong about the scores like
yeah i don't know what you all were
talking about the the first season of
stranger things deserves to be where it
is at 97 percent fresh but i look at
this overall average of 93 across the
three seasons that feels a little high
for me because i agree with eric that
the second season
is the worst of the three and it really
suffered from a sophomore slump to the
point where jacqueline this must have
been you season five of the west wing
because i barely got through this season
i do feel like season three rebounded
somewhat 89 still feels a little high
because i just thought they were leaning
so hard into 80s nostalgia and by that
point i just wanted a more fun story
than just like hey here's what 7-eleven
used to look like but i still enjoy the
show i'm very excited about the new
season i i can say that every season i
think is fresh although season two is
like right at the 60 cut line for me but
uh yeah that first season really blew me
away when i like everyone else had never
heard about it saw it was trending on
twitter binged it in two nights and was
forever changed uh before we get
too deep into it mark can you give us
the who what when where and why of all
that has happened in season in the
seasons of stranger things going back to
season one as quickly as you can sir um
this show is about kids and adults that
kind of act like kids sometimes and when
one of those kids named will goes
missing in season one hell breaks loose
in the small town of hawkins indiana and
it turns out to be a lot more than just
a missing kid because he is in this
nether region called the upside down
that features demogorgons and a whole
lot of crazy scary stuff and that's
basically who we're going up against for
all three of these seasons so far
luckily we have an ace in the hole in
the form of 11. played by millie bobby
brown who has some supernatural
telekinetic sort of powers we're still
figuring out how she got it why does her
nose bleed all the time and why is she
so strong and powerful enough to defeat
something like a demogorgon she has a
surrogate father figure in uh sheriff
hopper played by david harbour and he
has a surrogate daughter because he lost
his daughter tragically a few years
before the events of the show and as
we've mentioned already multiple times
the show lovingly takes place in the
1900s and 80s remember the mall everyone
remember the mall it was a lot of fun to
go to the mall and that stranger things
in a nutshell yeah back when we had
malls the mall in my hometown is now
community college if you want to know
how that economy is doing great eric
eric are you too young to remember how
exciting it was to have your your mom
drop you off at the mall on friday
afternoon i don't know if it's maybe
just like a regional thing or not but
this it's funny because i was thinking
in the back of my head i still go to the
mall
maybe they're not by you guys anymore
but yeah like the mall i grew up with is
still here and around the country is
like if i need to go uh close shopping
or whatever i'll go to a mall so they're
still there you got to look for them
though they're like diamond in the rough
i guess
see all the malls i go to now are not
really malls because they're not covered
so it's like the grove or like topanga
like i guess technically that's a mall
but if you have to have an umbrella to
traverse it i don't consider that a mall
yeah there's a lot of like open concept
malls like i need like i need a food
court and like you know the chance that
you might get beat up somewhere it's not
happening
around the corner from a total wine and
you know a world market it's just
different it's very different right it
is different it is different anyway why
don't we go ahead and see what tim ryan
has to say about what the critics
thought about these various seasons in
our segment two minutes with tim brian
cue the music
[Music]
when it comes to both critics and
audiences the first three seasons of
stranger things have been remarkably
consistent here's a quick rundown season
one of stranger things is certified
fresh at 97 on the tomato meter with 91
reviews and it has a 96 audience score
season 2 is certified fresh at 94 with
150 reviews and it has a 90 audience
score season 3 is certified fresh at 89
with 140 reviews and it has an 86
audience score overall the series as a
whole is fresh at 93 and it has a 91
audience score so what do the critics
have to say in a fresh review for season
one mary mcnamara of the los angeles
times wrote for the most part and in
absolute defiance of the odds stranger
things honors its source material in the
best way possible by telling a sweet and
scary story in which monsters are real
but so are the transformative powers of
love and fealty however in a rotten
review for season three tory preston of
pajiba wrote stranger things one and two
offered cohesive stories that surpassed
the weaknesses of some of the parts
where a stranger thinks three had some
truly outstanding parts that did not
make up for the weakness of the overall
story arc so that's stranger things
let's kick it back to jacqueline and
mark two people who are on a curiosity
voyage and need a podcast to travel back
to you folks
i do love him i would have loved it a
little bit more if he would have sang
the theme to never ending story but
way to go tim i really appreciate that
um let's go ahead and start talking and
breaking it down because there's a lot
to digest here over three seasons of
television so
let's go ahead and move into
the tv talk section brian cue the music
[Music]
gotta like switch my brain a bit we
normally do movies but now we're into tv
talks so
mark you kind of talked about it but it
legitimately was a phenomenon when it
first came out um eric when did you when
did stranger things come into your
consciousness was it comic-con led you
into it like like how did you get
excited for it i i similar to what mark
said i i just saw that everyone was
talking about it i guess or you know i
think leading up to it everyone was
talking about it uh so i caught it when
it debuted on netflix and it and also
like mark said that's a binge
immediately kind of show uh it was it
was kind of at the beginning of binging
whereas now you see a lot of the
different streaming services actually
switching back to weekly which i
personally prefer i like to ruminate on
these things and and keep myself you
know uh uh excited every week but this
was at the height of the binging
phenomenon really i would say or the
dawn of it at least and i finished it i
want to say in a day i think me and my
friend sat down and like through the day
roommates came in and were like oh wait
what is this oh i want to watch and they
just like came in at different episodes
and then went back later um
but uh i will say this though not to get
too ahead of ourselves because we're
talking about the first season but the
second season i didn't watch until the
third season was coming out because i
just for some reason wasn't hooked
enough from the end of the first season
to be excited about the second season
mark what about you what are your
season one reactions to stranger things
so i i this was sort of like my peak
years of going to comic-con and covering
everything that was announced at
comic-con i do not remember if stranger
things had a presence at comic-con
before season one but i i the way i
remember it i never heard of this show
literally never heard of the show don't
remember seeing a trailer or anything
for it until i was on the road at the
cincinnati funny bone which technically
i think is in kentucky and
i was
i i did the show on thursday there's one
show thursday two fridays saturday one
sunday so i do the show thursday and i
go back to my hotel room and i just
start you know trolling around on
twitter and i see stranger things and
everybody's talking about the show
stranger things and i'm like oh well i'm
my laptop i can watch netflix this is
exciting technology let's fire it up see
what
and i fell in love with the feel of the
show i mean we all know how i feel about
children but i like these kids well
enough and it was just the overall vibe
that it was retro it was spooky it was
funny it was scary at points and i just
got so invested into the multiple
storylines going on it was nice to see
somebody that i recognized like a winona
ryder but then it was also great to meet
these new talents that were emerging on
the scene and that went i loved the
first season and that carried me through
the excitement of seeing them do a panel
the next year at comic-con previewing
season two and that trail where
everybody lost their minds was such a
cool trailer um but yeah season one was
a binge uh for me and i i think i mixed
eric i like some shows that make us wait
a week to watch the new one but i also
like every so often just having that
weekend where it's like all right let's
just knock out everything ozark has to
show me yeah there's better call saul's
good weekly bridgerton is good in a
binge those there's differences there's
that kind of vibe yeah richardson is
good and a [ __ ] sacrilegious
hurt me stab me in the vivaldi why don't
you you trying to keep it dragging out
yeah
uh we will discuss like your thing with
the the greatest showman and musicals i
also have to but my love affair with
romance novels is deep and unabiding in
the end
yeah like it's a thing uh one thing i
will say about stranger things in the
early seasons which the secondary
seasons i feel have not as created is in
the early seasons it was erica it was
barb it was so many side characters that
made people fall in love with the show
more so than the actual leads like the
leads are rather insufferable
if i'm being honest like and i'm just
being honest like privileged kids from
indiana is a really hard time for me to
be like yay you are struggling sorry i
just didn't get it but
when they had like erica make fun of
them i loved that when you had barb
being like oh my god we're in your teen
angst drama and i'm just going to be
your best friend and i don't want to be
like i loved all of the sort of
i would say modern sentiments or just
sort of like meta commentary on on this
stuff more than anything else so i think
those were the things about the early
seasons that i really really really
loved and i think that's what made me
forgive some of the more like i would
say this is um
something so nostalgic is gonna feel
like it's from a different time and it
will get boring unless they have
characters like that or moments like
that which makes me think like one of my
favorite i don't have a favorite episode
but one of my favorite moments in the
entire thing was i think episode 1
season 2 when um
it was i guess it was i want to say that
they were arguing about who got to play
venkman
and they wanted to give the black kid
winston and as every black kid who only
had to play the black kid in power
rangers in every other show
i felt that so deep in my soul i was
like oh y'all got black people in the
stranger things writer room for season
two because that's exactly what that is
like nobody who hasn't lived that didn't
feel that so that to me was one of my
favorite moments episodes all together
why can't there just be two venkmans
because there's only one victory in real
life we planned this months ago i'm
venkman dustin stanz you're egon and
you're winston i specifically didn't
agree to winston yes you did i don't
think he did no one wants to be winston
man what's wrong with winston what's
wrong with winston he joined the team
super late he's not funny and he's not
even a scientist yeah but he's so cool
if he's cool then you'd be winston i
can't why not
because
because you're not black i didn't say
that you thought it what about you eric
favorite favorite episode favorite
moment what do you got well if we're
just talking season one i i would say
that the oh no overall oh overall okay
cause i was gonna say well in season one
uh favorite what favorite thing i can
think of really is the uh the waffles
the introduction of the waffles uh the
the whole you know when she's in the
store you know and whatever gets the
waffles because i personally uh
was very impressed with yeah they're
doing an 80s nostalgia thing but
they did actually create something
iconic and it felt like that scene like
just her you know her outfit you know
you saw it at halloween you still see
the halloween her outfit the shaved head
the waffles the whole deal feels like
something still if i go back and watch
that it feels like something that we're
seeing a remake of that actually is from
the 80s it feels like they're doing
their take on something that actually
was from the 80s and i find that to be
extremely impressive when you can do 80s
nostalgia but make your own thing and
have it feel genuinely like an old
school thing i find that very impressive
and i feel like that was the most iconic
uh
most iconic you know kind of visual uh
from the first season and again the
first season's not really my favorite so
you know the the
favorite parts i have are more are
things like that i would say overall the
the ending of season three had to be my
favorite i think that the big fight in
the mall was just
the the best i don't know where they go
from here i really think it was that
good i don't know where they go from
here i think they peaked and i'm very
curious to see what comes next but it
was an incredible finale that now
apparently is only the middle of the
story so i guess we'll see what happens
there i'll tell you where they go eric
where they go in season four is no
supernatural entities whatsoever they
just figure out puberty like that's the
only thing that is facing them figured
it out a lot yeah
they schedule like 20 right yeah it's
it's like the cast of 90210 when they're
all like 35 playing scene you know
sophomores in high school yeah um i what
i do love about this show i'm full
disclosure i do a show called versus and
i'm writing stranger things versus cobra
kai and it's funny because cobra kai
like takes place in modern day but it
has a lot of 80s nostalgia this show
takes place back in the 80s and it's
reminding us how much fun we had but i
agree with eric's point that this show
it does you know sometimes it relies too
heavily on hey look at how fun the 80s
were but most of the time it really
sticks the landing and for me my
favorite episode in season one and
overall is the bathtub is the name of
the episode and that's basically where
it's towards the end of the season it's
the seventh episode and this is where we
get the warning from lucas that agents
are about to come search the house and
so we have to go on this like e.t
feeling adventure and 11 is using her
telepathy to like flip vans and then
later on in the episode she's kind of
sensing what's going on the upside down
she can confirm will is alive which is
like a huge thing and barb is not alive
and that sucks for barb um justice for
barb but then we also get to see
some some fun demogorgon action we also
get to watch hopper and joyce uh team up
as they're trying to break into the lab
unsuccessfully though it may be it's fun
to watch their chemistry but the overall
feeling of this is i think exactly what
the duffer brothers were going for when
they created the show and that's to make
us feel the way that we all felt when we
were kids seeing e.t levitate bikes for
the first time yeah listen i will also
say to on the whole like
where we end up with like just how crazy
the magic and crazy how the special
effects get i did give stranger things a
lot of crap for their price tag but the
later season's effects compared to the
first season is just kind of astounding
and exciting is unbelievable it actually
makes the first two look bad yes and so
the fact that we're able to do that on
television i am of course being like
facetious in it that price tag will
always have me be like this is not game
of thrones like they got to make swords
i get that you know what i mean but like
you know whatever
you think the sword budget is more than
it is more than it costs to put a
replica rc cola and a 7-eleven yeah
because you've got to get that right and
they make dragons over there too like
let's be real like they all have this
but let's be honest they also like if
the stranger thinks season five just
doesn't end up being the last season of
game of thrones they win so like we're
good um the other thing too and eric you
sort of spoke and touched on this is
this idea of the first season of
stranger things really felt like to your
point of period piece it felt like a
movie made within the vein and within
the sentiment as if the duffer brothers
were creating something that could have
been created right alongside amblin and
those early sort of like um days of that
of that sort of nostalgia or i would say
the nostalgia that we live in now was
created in that time and this and those
first seasons
later seasons feel like throwbacks later
seasons feel much more like we have more
modern sensibilities and we are
definitely calling back to this thing
but we are no longer trying to create it
with that sort of amblinesque uh vibe
and that sort of it it's not emulating
it anymore you're right as it goes on
yeah yeah and and when you look at
something which it shouldn't because
again they're trying to branch out and
create their own things but if you look
at something like the atom project that
is a complete and simple thing that
lives within that one space and that's
what the first season of stranger things
is and i'm not gonna lie to you as they
get further away from the things that
they idolize and are trying to comment
on
that's i think where they get in a
little bit of trouble with the
storytelling in it and it doesn't i
think work as well which then leads some
of us to like say which are the moments
that we like less and i think for me
personally there's one episode that a
lot of people like come against is the
lost daughter uh mark i was gonna say
are we gonna all agree on this
i don't think so because i actually
liked that episode i did not i did not
understand the whole thing about hating
it other than i think people are
impatient and they were binging
but that's my theory first so eric you
just like the lost daughter i'm guessing
yeah well yeah sorry not to not so buddy
because you're gonna ask mark there but
yes okay i will say uh it's for a couple
of reasons number one it uh it's my
least favorite because it comes it
literally interjects at like the peak of
the action we're about to have the
demogorgons attacking everybody we're
waiting for we know that uh what's his
face uh aston what's his name is sean
aston i i forget is the actor's name
always but um he's about we know he's
yeah he's about to bite it we know it's
coming he's been the whole show he's
been like i love being alive and we know
he's never gonna live so uh we where
it's like you're excited you're ready
and then it cuts to this
thing with 11. which uh the thing is i
actually and this is maybe here's the
hot take uh brian can we play the hot
take music great thank you um
here's the hot take um i don't think 11
really matters anymore after season one
i i feel like they're shoehorning her in
pretty much at this point maybe in
season three it got better in season two
keep in mind they keep her away from the
crew the whole time because if she was
there it's like captain marvel if she
was there they'd already win all she has
to do is just show up and do her thing
the same thing she did in season one so
the fact that she already felt sort of
like irrelevant to the show at that
point and they gave her a whole episode
with these middle-aged guys that are for
some reason like hanging out with kids
as outcasts or whatever millie bobby
brown is like 14 and there's like 30 40
year old men and they're like we're the
freaks yeah you are freaks you are
freaks get away from her um that whole
thing i just didn't care for it and then
at the end of the or maybe the beginning
of the next episode it gets right back
to where we were at the beginning of it
and i'm like yeah just we didn't even
need to watch it just cut it forget it
see i i liked having i liked having 11
and hopper's relationship like growth
like i like seeing that father-daughter
stuff expand and i think that it's an
interesting point you make because i
still feel like 11 is necessary to the
show but her powers were so
overwhelmingly new and supernatural
feeling in season one that it's it's
sort of like all right now
where do we go from here and that's why
i feel like season two took such a dip
down but then we did rebound pretty well
with season three her powers are much
cooler in season three than ever before
because season one and two all she does
is scream with her hand up
the end that's it in season three she's
throwing the demogorgon around the room
and it's the coolest thing and they it's
like they finally figured out i figured
it out it's like a jedi it's it's like
luke skywalker gets his ass kicked by
the rancor if he's fresh off the you
know rescuing the princess and blowing
up the death star in the first star wars
but it's the jedi training kick it in
man i'm telling you jaclyn this is th
this is what this show is predicated
upon is learning your powers and
figuring out how to get into college yes
and i will say that
you're muted sweetheart oh shoot sorry
i was just about to say well it's
because of the dog i didn't want you to
hear the dog having a whole conversa
conversation with you excited uh i was
just gonna say though uh not gonna say
it's completely whatever but this idea
of you know training your senpai it's
like a bit on the nose honestly in like
80s whatever i was more enjoying the
more tender heartfelt moments like david
harper writing a letter about keeping
the door open like that's where this
thing really hits yeah yeah it's really
good and everything that that doesn't i
feel it isn't but no not the lost
daughter she's still
important and for moments like i just
said i do feel
she is the data character from star trek
the next generation she is the spa
character from the original series it's
this idea of a very highly intelligent
probably one of the most powerful people
in the crew also being in some ways the
most vulnerable because their lack of
human interactions and experiences i
love that idea of a character it gives
them so many more interesting places to
go that's what the lost daughter was
that was something that had never
been given a chance for individuality
been given individuality because
remember she just went from her father's
control to a group that was the first
time she got to actually be
some of herself and i think that is
important i do think that it's not a
wasted episode i just think if you put
it in the middle of where it was yeah
and people are binging
they're gonna be upset but if that
wasn't a show that you didn't binge i
don't know if it would have been um the
same sort of whatever mark what about
you what's your like least favorite
aspect of the series overall i think my
least favorite aspect of the series is
when
it it does feel like we're just filling
time i i don't feel like the this the
episode we're just talking about
was necessarily the worst culprit in
that but i even feel like as much as i
loved the end of season three and that
battle at star court mall was just so
epic and expansive i did i felt the the
length of it and it just it felt like we
were we have you know all this money to
spend now so why not just throw
everything at the wall and it just
didn't feel as as clean from a
storytelling standpoint i think it just
got a little too bloated for its own
good and a little too reliant on how
much we did love them all having said
that there are still a lot of things
that i liked in in eric's favorite
episode which which is not limited to
the fact that we're having this battle
while there's a bunch of theater goers
inside a movie theater watching back to
the future like it's a it's it's a
really fun juxtaposition and yet another
reminder as to exactly what time per
period we're in no that is that was a
very cool poll it very much felt very
twister
remember twister when they're watching
the shining and the tornado hits it felt
very that when i was watching it uh
so characters i think i i'd definitely
go ahead and say eric i don't think uh
uh 11 is going to be yours but who's
your favorite and who are your least
favorite characters yeah so the thing is
it's not that eleven's my least favorite
character so much as it just and
specifically in season two it felt like
they didn't know what to do with her and
they just sidelined her because again if
she was there they wouldn't have had any
of the problems they were having because
she just shows up and defeats the
monster in the same way that she did in
season one uh which i didn't care for
myself i thought that it was a little
bit um
you know like uh convenient i guess in
season three it felt much more natural
so eleven uh not my least favorite
character um by any means uh overall but
in season two so i'll stick with her
just just because that's easier than
thinking of somebody else right now my
favorite character i honestly think is
billy i mentioned it before um billy who
of course i'm devastated that well it
seems like there might be something with
him because we see a little tease you
know you never know but um but obviously
he he died and i i cried my eyes out i'm
a little baby boy i cried when he died
in season three um season two his
introduction was very interesting
because if you remember i didn't know
what exactly they were going with uh
they didn't make it really clear at
first um i was i was iffy on the
character because in season two he was
looking at um
the only black character in the show and
saying stay away from him and i was like
oh so this is a racist character we
don't like him obviously turns out that
wasn't necessarily what he was all about
they picked maybe the wrong character
for him to be pointing at to you know
whatever that's where my mind went um
but it turned out that he had a lot more
going on to the point where he got some
backstory in season three that was very
impressive and yeah uh and i and the
thing is i remember thinking in season
two we got we got a lot of backstory of
eleven and i was like there's another
character here that we need more
backstory from and then they kind of
answered my answered my prayers there a
little bit with him um i think he's my
favorite because he went from the bottom
to the top because at first i thought
that he was like a really rotten
character and he even though he was an
adversary obviously
in season three of course he was being
controlled it wasn't necessarily him and
i am hoping that somehow he
shows up again we'll see what happens
but i think uh yeah i gotta go with him
i gotta go with him well who's your
least favorite
i'm gonna stick with eleven even though
it's not technically appropriate you
know whatever
a least favorite overall is hard to say
um but but because of season two i'm
gonna go with her so specifically eleven
in season two is my least favorite not
overall i'm gonna go with that okay mark
what about you face uh favorite and
least so my i'll start with my least
favorite i don't know why i can't get
behind a performance this guy's done in
so long but like is something about the
way matthew modine plays the character
just bothers the crap out i i don't know
what it it's probably a me thing and not
a matthew mo deed thing but i just feel
like he's over i'm like you've
interviewed this man in my presence
just the he's and he's great in vision
quest he's great in memphis bell but i
just can't do him in the dark knight
rises and maybe that transfers over to
the way he plays martin brenner i just
can't i i can't get on board with this
so i was thrilled when paul reiser
showed up as sort of like a wait do we
trust this adult kind of guy in season
two my favorite is so tough because i
really find something that i can enjoy
genuinely out of all of the the main kid
cast but there's just something extra
with dustin and
gate monterrazzo plays him so well but
then when we also get to see the way
that him and steve sort of team up and
in season three that that's such that's
so fun even though it's very distracting
to look at joe keary who plays the
character of steve because he might have
the best head of hair like i've ever
seen on a human in my life like his hair
is just
it's so stupid thick and full and just
luscious i'm like it doesn't matter what
science does for hair restoration it's
never gonna be able to give you that
head of hair i don't know how that
happened but keep that lettuce kid it is
it is just gorgeous i want to see you
guys make shirts by the way it's not
it's not a matthew modine thing it's a
me thing it's a me thing
i like a shirt i mean honestly like we
have so many other things to deal with
on the podcast but if ever we're sitting
on an abundance of time yes a merch shop
would definitely be a part of my thing
in fact rotten tomatoes is wrong folks
if you guys think we should have merch i
think we do let us know at rotten
tomatoes is wrong email lucy and be like
merch we want merch i want something
that says the ketchup crew i want
something that says see y'all next time
y'all and i want something mark what's
your catchphrase his catchphrases you
know how i feel about kids let's be
clear you did say that earlier don't
step father wait i'm i'm i'm babysitting
molly like that's what the shirt can say
or something yeah
molly the wonder dog snoring who as
we're recording this episode is
celebrating her 15th birthday so happy
birthday to maui the wonder dog um
the merch that we would make for
jacqueline is and this is like merch
that you can order and you can customize
it however you want but it's the blank
of it all yeah
exactly like for me our combined shirt
would just be like it's the matthew
modine of it all yeah
there you go actually that is the thing
i will call publicist to be like i need
to talk about
the this of it all and it'll be like
some aspect of the movie oh i love this
so much anyway back on track just a
moment really clear before we have like
this sidelined merch conversation which
by the way i it will not even be a
sideline it'll be a complete one um
i i just want to add this
my favorite characters are never really
full characters because they get to just
come in i love day players i love people
that come in murder a scene just steal
every inch of everything and then just
watch as everyone else is just trying to
so brett gilman who plays the conspiracy
gary guy yes live live live first of all
love him in everything he's the only
american in flea bag and just completely
makes sense like that right there is
just incredible the fact that he just
shows up in that and is still one of the
best parts he's great in this uh he has
so many incredible movies so he's up
there erica is another one because yes i
just wish i was erica when i was that
age i was not i was very much like
hiding away i was wearing more will
buyers who thought like erica like i was
just like kind of hiding away reading my
books but i had the wit of erica so i
love her least favorite character mike
mike wheeler you are such trash you are
so whiny
you were so whiny you were so annoying
you were so the worst versions of every
boy that had your existence just be
happy brief privilege don't be mad do
not you do not get to be angsty sir just
get over it like i'm just i was so over
him i was so over him in the last two
seasons he was every worst example of 13
year old boys i just i hated him and he
was annoying and he was whiny and he was
entitled and i just did not enjoy it
man between you and me mike and 11 are
our least favorite characters and we're
still watching the show i was gonna say
like i i did i think a lot of our
listeners and viewers did not expect to
hear such slander against mike and
eleven today i love you mike i love you
11.
him on his worst day he's still fine but
when he whines he whines he just whines
he also has one of those like he
more so i think than any of the other
kids suffers from the i'm growing up and
i can't help it kind of thing
like because
like dustin and lucas to a degree still
look like they can they can pull off
playing younger kids easier than mike
ken but mike is luckily blessed with
possibly the greatest marquee name of
all time yeah i mean
the name finn wolfhard and millie bobby
brown i could enjoy saying those names
out loud all day yeah yeah oh and by the
way i love phil finn wolfhard because
one of the things i absolutely love
about him is he could have very much
leaned into his teen heartthrob status
but he's very much like no i just like
to make movies and play with my band you
know what i mean like he just seems to
be very about his own thing so no i love
him and i and honestly if it was him as
a 13 year old i would follow that dude's
entire life i'm like yeah i want to hear
more about you give me your angsty team
drama i can be with it and not hate you
mike wheeler is the worst but i think
they're doing that on purpose because
most of us are awful when we're
teenagers so it's completely authentic
in that respect does not mean it makes
me he makes my left eye twitch
this is legit like without question he
makes my left eye twitch i cannot change
it other than that there's so many other
great characters though i love what
david harper does as i was just gonna
say we gotta get at least
yeah you know hopper is so so so i think
just doing his best and just trying and
i really love him and is doing his best
just trying dad stuff because that to me
is also real and have you guys caught by
the way all the i don't know if you you
know how deep you've dug into stranger
things but it is actually tied into
hellboy and if you look really closely
you can see there are hints and nods to
hellboy throughout and the thing is as
we get closer to the finale it's gonna
cross over into hellboy i'm just saying
where is he where's david harbor right
now hell he went to hell at the end of
season three okay he got blasted to hell
it's russia
i mean he's in russia right now
i'm not gonna say you're wrong about
that but also let's be real i think
that's just david harper being friends
with the duffer brothers and being like
we're trying to get a sequel i'm just
saying listen just keep an eye on that
hand that's all i'm saying okay i love
the way we meet hopper though in the in
season one where he's just passed out
and you got a bunch of beer cans
everywhere it's like we know exactly who
this guy is the role of playing that
small town sheriff who is just trying to
pass the buck of responsibility onto
anybody else is great and it would have
been fun enough as a superficial
character on that wavelength but then
when we get to know his backstory it
just it means so much more and then
we're rooting for him and we're rooting
for winona ryder's joyce just to find
some sort of happiness in their lives
now because they've been through so much
as humans and his parents that you just
want him to have a fun date night where
he gets to dress up his magnum pi but
see
here's the conundrum for me is that i
went back and i watched a couple
episodes of season one of stranger
things and i remember the only real
criticism of the show at the time was
that they thought when a lot of people
said winona ryder's overcooking it and
i'm like have you ever lost your kid in
the upside down when when they start
communicating by the christmas lights oh
my god what a moment that is no i
thought that was absolutely perfect and
i think it actually showed first of all
if the internet and pandemic proved us
anything i watched a lot of crazy people
in the pandemic videos losing their
stuff yeah
what what she goes through and the
upside down ain't nothing
together i've seen people have a
stronger reaction about you know
walking with a mask in whole foods so
like she's allowed to lose it a bit over
her child being disappeared and possibly
murked by an ever-present being like i'm
okay with that one i also too
want to just say like the duffer
brothers for you know
they are loud man like you know what i
mean like if you're simone biles you get
to walk with swagger they got rejected
thanks while cough meyer for telling us
there are 37 network executives right
now kicking themselves because they had
stranger things and they turned it down
i always say though the show that gets
turned down is never the show that you
see the reason why all the women turned
down pretty woman was because it was a
really dark
like she was addicted to drugs horrible
movie that was not the pretty woman that
we got to see so the movies or the show
that stranger thing was going to be when
it got rejected was not necessarily what
we get to see but i love that these guys
persevered and they made their they made
their show and also i don't go to
stranger things for subtlety
i'm not watching it like oh i can't wait
for this really subtle little drama like
no i'm going for fireworks and that's
why i love the finale of season three i
got fireworks
exactly and look i mean they definitely
i think care about nostalgia but they
also have made a lot of i would say
efforts to make this the most marketable
things like there are stranger things
doritos on the shelves right now ladies
and gentlemen as we get ready for season
four they have broken the mainstream it
just it hits on a different level so
eric where where are you on your
anticipation level of season four are
you rushing to it where are you at
so i'm mixed uh because i really do
think that they
they did a great job wrapping up
everything in season three and it felt
like you know hopper's dead billy's dead
and it was like it it felt very final
you know what i mean it felt like this
could be an ending and that's always a
concern when you're like this could be
the end of something and then it
continues uh my favorite tv shows are
the ones that end that just end when
they're supposed to end when they should
you know um the leftovers for example
three seasons we're done that's it love
that show
excuse me don't need any more run better
call solve final season right now i
don't need more let's wrap it up let's
make let's keep it good so i
unfortunately i'm worried that we will
have peaked at three for me at least
peaked at three and now maybe it's gonna
go down when it could have ended on top
but at the same time i am very excited
because i want to see what happens with
um hopper i want to see you know i i
don't watch trailers and stuff but i've
seen little things on social media so i
know that he's around i know you know
whatever i know that billy is alluded to
here and there so i'm excited for that
uh and the other reason i'm excited is
honestly just to watch it with my buddy
miles we we do commentary tracks over on
pretty much it and the most fun thing is
is watching shows like this with my
friends and so i'm excited about the
communal aspect of it that's going to be
really fun it's still a fun event yeah
it's still a fun event to
talk about whether you're watching with
people in person or you you just get to
tweet about it once you get back into
your twitter after it got hacked and
look at what season four could give us
and what i'm really excited about is i
think they are going to lean into the
fact that these kids are so much older
now than they were in the first range of
things i think they're going to have fun
with that because as as older as they
are they're still kids and they're still
trying to figure out their life and
they're still trying to to navigate
you know the waters of dating and
getting good grades and trying to figure
out what you want to do with the rest of
your existence there's a lot of fun
questions you could ask but the big
issue i've had and i hope it gets
rectified i don't i think this is going
to take place in 86 i believe this next
season they haven't had not one that
i've spotted van halen poster in any of
the kids rooms not one van halen shirt i
know that the music is expensive y'all i
i realize it's it's
much more expensive than white snake but
you got to give me something all right
86 is when hagar joined the band you
could easily have a 5150 poster or wreck
somewhere in the background yeah how
expensive is it
like it's there yeah
so that's basically what i'm looking for
that that and and just to see where
where the duffer brothers want to take
this mythology
leading into what we presume is going to
be the final season season five this is
sort of like the setup but eric i feel
like we we all get a mulligan after
season two for me anyway so i i kind of
strike season two from the record and
i'm like all right this is really my
season three of strangers okay fair
enough yeah
strikes she's
man
me in season two i'm gonna have to do a
deep dive on just season two because
there is shade abounding it and it has
literally some of my favorite moments
including the emergence of erica
including all of i think every aspect of
what we were able to see with all the
characters that we didn't get more time
with so i was about it even if you guys
weren't uh just some final things on
stranger things the one thing i will say
with this is
it has become a phenomenon i'm so glad
of what it's done but now that it's
reaching its swan song and especially as
it has been so synonymous with the
success of netflix
they had squid game which is great but i
wonder what is going to be the next
english language show that captures the
way that stranger things did bridgeton
is its own thing and it's true but it's
not the same as stranger things stranger
things was all-encompassing men women
every demographic i love bridgerton but
ladies and the gays we are making that
show and we are just
dragging you straight boys along for the
ride stranger things it's so funny you
say that because i was talking i was
just doing commentary tracks for
bridgeton actually and i was talking
about how i love benedict i think he's
he's extremely attractive and i was like
ladies and gays and i was like wait
which category am i in if i also think
no i mean we're bringing y'all along for
the ride they're definitely straight men
that are in here but this this show was
both created and i'm not kidding you by
black women and gay men when i tell you
this is my stuff this is the stuff
like that yeah but
rhymes and the creator chris gay man
black woman gay man we made this baby
and it is bridgeton
is all encompassing though you are
correct i agree with that i love
bridgeton but i agree yeah and i will
say this as great as as as widely viewed
as stranger things season three was
season three dropped and netflix very
rarely reports any of their numbers
because they're stored next to the ark
of the covenant but
season three in its first month got
560 million hours
of of views
that is would be a record if not for
squid game which in its first month on
netflix did
1.65 billion hours
of abuse insane yeah yeah yeah and
that's and that's the kind of numbers
you're talking about and in truth i
don't think anything can uh replicate
that even stranger things but no that is
it for our tv talk section let's go
ahead and rip open the mailbag brian cue
the music
[Music]
this is from the ketchup crew member
robbie miss skimming mexican skimming it
sounds good it sounds like a fun new
sport i like this robbie mcskimming
sorry sir thank you for the assist mark
hey love your podcast i was wondering
could you ever cover the pirates of the
caribbean franchise sir
sir are you watching youtube channels
right now on legal tv
well this might be the best time to do
it right with the seo who said who says
who says i will wait until there is less
chum in the water as they say but yes i
would like to cover pirates of the
caribbean because fun fact who people
don't know i
loved the first movie i've seen it
probably 60 times i love love love that
movie i listen to the soundtrack
the rest of them i have loved
moments but the very first one
to me
you are perfect
i saw that one like twice in the theater
like like went like specifically twice
to go see it and i was like you have to
go see this is the greatest thing ever
and i had never even ridden the ride i
just liked the movie okay you see the
ride is boring now enough enough next
i'm a theme park guys i love the ride
theme park
are you one of these disney adults are
you one of these no oh if anything i'm
more of a universal adult i guess
technically because i'm a universal pass
holder no i uh i i love parks
mommy ride is down for refurbishment
right now and we just hope that brendan
stays in it after oh man you really
never okay basically i forgot this next
time thank you that's right that's right
mark what about you how are you on the
pirates
i love the first one the rest of them
all run together uh i think it was the
first movie i saw when i moved to l.a
was pirates
wow
wow
when eric was still a zygote i was gonna
say i was wanna know i don't wanna know
no i will say actually that is uh uh the
i think that's my first
i mean when did that i realistically
that came out like 2003 so i was
actually i was like 12. so i i've seen
movies and stuff but it might it's my
earliest memory of johnny depp actually
i think i don't know that i necessarily
knew i'd seen maybe stuff with him but i
don't know that i necessarily knew who
he was and then i saw that movie and i
was like who is that guy and that's when
i like realized like oh this is this is
a big actor i didn't realize you know
yeah i was like 12 i was like 11. yeah i
didn't really realize and then i went
back and i was like oh that's the guy in
this movie yeah exactly
a little different though when you're a
kid
you can't tell who's who exactly when
they're in makeup but that was there
anything you want about johnny depp to
me he's always going to be the guy that
got sucked into a bed in a nightmare in
elm street this is true to me he's
always going to be mort rainey from
secret window oh really see i used to
watch reruns in the morning when i was
getting ready and so at first he was 21
jump street because i watched him right
now that was my first one eric sir thank
you so much for joining us tell folks
where they can find you and what you're
working on well thank you so much for
having me again you guys are a blast
this is always fun um and uh you can
find me on pretty much it uh if you go
on youtube and look up pretty much it
that's probably the easiest way to find
us um you'll you'll find our stranger
things one two and three videos
depending on when this goes up we might
have a video up for stranger things 3.5
which is hellboy and then of course
stranger things four on the way can't
wait i love this also he's not letting
this hellboy thing go he really is
just you gotta read between the lines
it's there i will i will i'll check it
out
um eric sir thank you so much for
joining us thank you guys and i want to
let everyone know if you're listening to
this first of all did you know that we
have other podcasts that are coming out
because that's right we have another
show one of which i host called the
after show and another one that mark
hosts called binge battle and both of
them will now be uh audio episodes that
you guys will be able to listen to on
our rotten tomatoes channels that is the
after show and binge battle the after
shows where we break down
shows that are coming out and get folks
to have a spoiler review of what
happened what didn't happen and looking
ahead to maybe see what happens next and
then binge battle mark why don't you
tell us what binge battle is about well
we take some beloved personalities from
inside and outside the world of
entertainment and we talk about a
particular show usually it's a streaming
series of some sort occasionally we'll
do a movie and we take some topics we
have a fun debate about it i award
points and it's just a celebration of
whatever we're talking about so it's a
very fun show for people to listen to
and very tough for me to decide who wins
and who loses because i love everyone i
do love this all right well for folks
please listen in you can see that on our
ott channels and on our podcast channels
again that is after show which went live
last week and [ __ ] battle which will be
live tomorrow 5 20. all right folks next
week you all need to tune in for mark
dinosaurs like even bigger dinosaurs
jurassic world jurassic world i really
thought you were doing the old movie
dinosaurs man i got excited oh you mean
the tv show dinosaur no that movie with
the like alice or whatever the hell
stupid movie that the ride is based on
at disney
world kingdom oh no
there's also a show the show is great
though oh there was a show okay that's
right i forgot everybody
oh my god anyway i thought you were
doing dinosaurs also
dinosaur one of the first black sitcoms
on main television if you guys don't
know that that's a black tv show check
out the dinosaur's hair black tv show we
might not even get to jurassic world
next week we got it sounds like we got a
lot of stuff to talk about i know if
there's shows about dinosaurs we can do
it anyway that's it for us this week
tune in for jurassic world where we
break down how dallas
bryce dallas howard was able to run in
those shoes we will be back ladies and
gentlemen for next week on rotten
tomatoes is wrong
see y'all then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you